hell would welcome to this video playing
your drug shift ditch it's a new
opponent so let's go further we Neji to
e7 yeah that's an interesting line I
have studied this a little bit and I
think it's quite interesting however
ultimately decided against that not
because them because of this setup why
anything there were there were some
issues that actually have forgotten
about what exactly troubled me since he
wants to play Bishop to g5 him check so
let's get some in some space there a
five
no I five okay um let's see I would like
to of course get rid of this piece I can
go 92 and maybe let's do this keep it
simple let's trade it clap we takes
context looks a little bit more
harmonious so b6 is just stopping c5 for
the moment go into F sex ok what is what
is he doing that for Queen f4 what's the
deal I try to double their to get to a 7
ultimately if you take screen takes
seems to it seems to prepare a five
favorite no he doesn't so let's cover
huh I thought he needed he needs upon
break here so I'm a bit surprised so was
it is not playing see success here maybe
I wonder if I should just trade currency
er that's probably not bad for me I mean
it looks weird in terms of porn
structure but the queenside is just
quite favorable maybe is just playing no
he takes so I have to bring the King to
d3 so that you for is protected p 8 so
here we go I wonder seagoing b5 here
maybe no no he isn't okay it's a funny
look
okay it doesn't get any better kak kak
hit no this cannot move this is funny so
let's see it is completely stalemated
that okay so how do I win this I can
bring the King to be fired right when he
also has to move them it suks one this
is actually zoosk lon maybe maybe I can
completely soup swung him now can you
play this as I thought he would as it
just too terrible to never be able to
move it shouldn't help actually um
Knight to f5 would be 64 no that's to c5
immediately this is clearer yeah so i
think i'll take the exchange here right
this is probably probably easiest or is
there something better i mean i really
like this soup wrong situation maybe
this is really funny let's let's use it
suits one
check yeah i take p 8 next and cha take
that dick before black resigns I
completely killed himself there I mean
here I don't don't think this is
anything really I mean white has a bit
more space but it should never lose for
black really but he put himself into a
pretty awful situation there I think
he'd be five is kind of its mandatory to
avoid any unpleasant moments yeah and i
think it's it's possible all right i was
thinking this well maybe maybe 93
captain's kind of thing yeah this is
equal right or taking maybe taking a
small precise and I'm not quite sure
okay this is actually kind of
interesting the app that that's equal
but now yeah things get somewhat
interesting but he really he really this
is this is crazy really thinking King
King back to see aid I mean the
situation is already pretty bad because
it's kind of you stalemated his book
them but
still fit you can certainly defend
better than getting into this active
suits one clock yeah I mean maybe I
should have done this this is this is
extremely extremely awful like yeah he's
running out of moves now yeah I can like
this is this and now you just wait there
cap and that's it him maybe this is what
I should have done it's a prevent be 500
yeah this is essentially the same thing
he's running and running on the same
time it was funny ok guys thanks for
watching